revenir quand même un peu sur le
fonctionnement du langage d'ailleurs
contrairement à ce que vous dites à
l'intérieur l'écriture inclusive il ya
débat effectivement entre les
transgenres qui veulent effacer la
binarité et ceux qui au contraire
veulent essayer systématiquement de
faire alterner les deux genres mais là
au départ qu'est ce qu'il ya au départ
c'est que ça a été introduit dans un
dictionnaire faut d'abord savoir ce que
c'est qu'un dictionnaire un dictionnaire
c'est pas une autorité malgré ce qu'on
dit dans les jeux télévisés me
affectionnait re ca enregistre un ca
n'édicte pas de règle les grammaires au
contraire et ict des règles et on
enregistre au sens peut enregistrer un
bout tout simplement parce qu'il est
utilisé même même avec une certaine
récurrence d'une part par exemple ils
ont introduit vaccinodromes distant ciel
et c'est ce qui est tout à fait
justifiée parce que c'est devenu très
récurrent la pandémie aubry et que ne
serait ce que parce qu'on veut aller
chercher la définition donc faut bien la
trouver dans le nord mais le problème de
yale c'est un mot grammaticales et quand
les dictionnaires intègre un mot
grammaticale c'est toujours en se
référant grammaire que je sache il n'y a
aucune grand mère qui a introduit yale
ça c'est un premier point est bon et le
deuxième point c'est que ça il faut
savoir comment fonctionne le langage
chacun est tout à fait libre d'inventer
les mots qui veut ça c'est évident
le problème c'est que est ce que c'est
un partage social ou pas donc d'une
manière générale on enregistre ce qui se
dit et ce qui se dit de façon quand même
assez récurrente est assez général donc
vous pouvez toujours avoir des
dictionnaires spécialisés pour avoir un
dictionnaire d'écriture inclusive comme
il ya des dictionnaire d'argot comme il
ya des dictionnaires technique mais si
vous êtes dans un dictionnaire de langue
général et dans une grammaire et ben il
faut se confirmer à ce qui est dans l'
usage et que je sache dit elle pour
l'instant n'est pas dans les usages
[Musique]